The first question involves a piece of technology that Galileo didn't have. A bicycle.
Now the bicycle is a wonderful machine.
And let's say you can ride here at a maximum speed of 12 m/s with an acceleration of 3 m/s².
So this means that if you start from rest, you can increase to a maximum speed of 12 at this rate.
Once you get to 12, you can't accelerate any more.
You could represent this graphically by plotting the velocity versus time.
At time 0, your bicycle is at rest. After 1 second your speed is increased by 3 m/s.
And in fact, you continue accelerating for the first 4 seconds until you reach your maximum speed.
After that, your speed remains constant.
What I want to know is how long will it take you to bike 96 m if you start from rest?
And for this problem, you might want to break it up into two sections,
the part where you're accelerating and the part where you're moving at constant speed.